[Music]
what's up everybody it's been a long
time since being flogged
just because TIFF and I we traveled so
much over the summer and we stockpiled
so much on travel vlogs that we haven't
actually had to vlog in a long time
feels like it's been like a month maybe
even more than that but yeah a lot has
changed since then no not really
nothing's changed at all I mean we've
just been spending the last month
editing all the bugs that we compiled
you know what's strange I've every
comments the ones that stand out to me
are the ones that complaining a lot we'd
never work we're always traveling abroad
to having fun do you know how many hours
I spend putting together the vlogs
after the traveling is done it's a lot
easier to travel without the camera on
and without talking to the camera it
takes me a long time to edit these vlogs
so doesn't seem like I'm not working
which is like I'm working too much I
could edit a whole lot less on this
channel yeah but with that said I know a
lot of you guys have expressed interest
in learning how to edit and learning how
to vlog and learning how to make videos
the way we make them on this channel for
the past year and a half I know that's a
long time feels like a long time TIFF
and I have secretly and quietly
assembled a video course on how to make
vlogs the way we do it on this channel
can't wait to share with you guys this
video course I'm gonna give you guys a
sneak peek what camera do I use that's
always like the question for you guys
camera cameras they all come in
different shapes sizes polity and prices
the best tip I can give you for that is
you're gonna have to tune in for that
tip we're gonna show you guys what kind
of equipment we use what kind of
equipment we recommend you to use how to
use it and what kind of footage to look
forward to provide you the best assets
to edit the way we edit and speaking of
editing BAM
everybody welcome back hope you guys had
a fun time shooting your vlogs we are
now about the tackled in my opinion the
most important part of our blogging
which is editing I asked my favorite
that's where it comes together and
answer all your ideas of how you shot it
comes to life and it just feels so
satisfying but yeah anyways this project
right here is a year and a half in the
making TIFF and I were balancing JK
beauty's the vlogging duties I'm working
on the movie with the JK guys so it's
just really hard to focus on one
particular project and get it done all
the way through when you're balancing so
many different things so if you guys are
interested in vlogging at least learning
how we vlog because I know a vlogging
comes in all different shapes and forms
these days but if you're interested in
how we do live long go down to the
description below there's a link to WWE
flippin camera calm that is our website
to our vlog course and from there you
can sign up for our mailing list and
we'll send you newsletters and updates
so get your camera's ready get your
editing software ready because we are
going in on how to fog the beauty of
working from home is that I don't have
to get ready to near the end of the day
I've been in my PJs the whole day really
yeah I just got ready pick you up yeah
thank you yeah what makes you want to
play the trumpet this year so what
instrument did you play last year violin
okay and then what made you want to go
away from the violin and towards the
trumpet now it's cooler than violin yeah
that's kind of fun too oh yeah cool what
kind of music wanna play with it jazz
jazz mr. jazz over here is that the
reason why you learn how to play piano
too yeah I want to learn piano because
it means the bestest thing uh la-la-land
I want to see you put it together now
I'm gonna get home I wanna show everyone
how you put trumpet together all right
before we go home what are we gonna do
we're gonna go grocery shopping I've got
a request from Isaac because we make
lunches for him every day before
and you do not want oatmeal pies and you
do not want Fig Newtons anymore because
that's what's in his lunch and you know
what you want in place of those no all
right we're gonna be shopping all right
so make them dinner tonight
got all this good stuff right here in
here right now chicken some but yet some
aromatics down there
where's the snack aisle which snack you
want for lunch
regular burritos north of Doritos how we
passed it right here you passed it do
you want the classic nacho cheese or the
other classic Cool Ranch or you'd be
going new school with the spicy sweet
chili oh I don't know how money doesn't
buy that one there are too much sodium
[Applause]
okay this one's my favorite one okay
yeah this is sweet I know that's why you
don't like it sweet chili yeah what is
it what is that it's like you don't be
over mommy mommy yeah yeah it's salty
it's sweet and tangy and a little bit
bitter from the chip it's pretty good
mommy to me that's a very sophisticated
word to know for a ten-year-old ooh
mommy probably gushers I might get in
place of the Fig Newtons no that's
another classic you're going to all the
classic stuff that I like when I was a
kid I never liked cookies or anything
like that cookies get old huh
ooh yes roll-ups fruit by the foot and
gushers which one's your favorite out of
the three of those me too
hey I finally make sure you got a cart I
still fits underneath it no crushing all
our rosemary down there and tying all
right so we got a biker three sons I
made the mistake of not getting a cart
you have to carry those you down yeah
it's like a little minion workout at the
grocery store yeah the flavors
any help with that oh I need to get all
its - then you make it all go to the
olives how about this like give you the
camera we switch places
okay I carry that very poor planning huh
huh yeah you're not very a good film er
I've met a very good shopper I realize
we're gonna get all this stuff oh yeah
ahlet's here we go go mediterranean
tonight looking for a Callum auntie kala
kalah
kalamata kalamata olives I've never
bought these olives before really yeah
so they look disgusting
they actually if you get see them they
look good but don't look so great but
it's gonna flavor to dish it's gonna
make it ooh mommy mommy let's check out
[Applause]
all right let's see that trumpet
[Music]
instrument piece
beautiful and then this is how you this
is good how you piece it together
oh that's fast that's a lot louder than
violin
you know Isaac was telling me in the car
he wants to practice it in the morning
you're gonna be like the military people
like that sister like that
like like in every camp movie that you
see you're gonna be the wake-up call for
everyone instead of a rooster
[Music]
oh yeah ass out ooh what's the gossip
[Music]
all right so tonight we are having
Mediterranean chicken just a random
recipe I pulled up from the internet
it's one of those one skillet type of
recipe so super easy to throw together
and you know feasable family without
having to create a lot of dishes to wash
which is always great
[Music]
how was your day baby it was good I had
a meeting with the guys and talking to
family and tuck to to odds that I
haven't talked to you in a long time
today oh cool
yeah how's your day it was good
basically I'm a deduction I'm a crack oh
that's right how is the doctor's
appointment good yes I went in to get an
ultrasound because one of my ovaries
like it hurts I went in to check check
it out and they were just saying like oh
it's just normal you have a lot of eggs
in that one ovary so you gotta do
something with that
yeah oh just something told me that next
time I get pregnant that would probably
be from that ovary because I have a
really ovary house mass but everything
else is normal it means that that ovary
makes a lot of eggs so human
an egg food woman from the man aka a
sperm never gotten awkward with this
kind of talk but now that there's people
watching
I need operation if science class Isaac
I mean you ask well Isaac doesn't want
to talk about this anymore he's ready to
eat and I am good you know how it goes I
had no idea this is my first time making
Mediterranean food ever
it's good sweet it has the case you can
flavor though really like sleek all your
food has like your sass on before you
know what I can taste to love that's
that ingredient that's what it is I
think what you're tasting and actually
though the fact that it's homemade
that's how homemade food tastes like
you're right I wouldn't know that I
broke the whole matrix post eight so
you're not pregnant
right no too
when I was in awkward why was it awkward
not the fact that you are in your
underwear in a rope how's that olive
sour sour you want another one I have
another one on my flavor here you're
okay you don't like the olives
oh it's so good no just like going on a
roller coaster roller coaster
[Music]